Brasil es el país del futuro… y parece
que lo seguirá siendo para siempre.
Últimamente se habla mucho de los escándalos
de corrupción en este país, de la crisis
por las que está pasando o por la violencia
urbana en ciudades como Rio de Janeiro.
¡Pero hay otro aspecto muy característico
de Brasil del que no se suele hablar tanto
en los medios de comunicación!
Hablamos del país más CARO de Latinoamérica.
Tal cual como lo oís.
Si queréis iros de compras en una ciudad
como Sao Paolo o Río de Janeiro, ya podéis
ir preparando la cartera, porque os puede
salir tan caro como en Nueva York o Londres.
Incluso los propios brasileños tienen una
palabra para esto.
Lo llaman el CUSTO BRASIL: algo así como
un sobrecoste que hay que pagar por el mero
hecho de vivir en el país de la samba y los
carnavales.
Vamos a tomar como ejemplo la hamburguesa
Big Mac que nos tomamos en un McDonalds.
Los que lleváis tiempo suscritos a VisualPolitik,
ya sabéis que el llamado índice Big Mac
se utiliza en economía como precio de referencia
para medir el coste de vida de un país.
Por ejemplo, en SUIZA, que es uno de los países
más ricos del mundo, el Big Mac nos costaría
el equivalente a 6,75 dólares.
Sin embargo, en PERU, que es un país más
pobre, nos saldría por 3,23 dólares.
Tiene lógica ¿Verdad?
A fin de cuentas, el sueldo medio que cobra
un Suizo es muy superior al de un peruano.
Pues bien, en Brasil, este Big Mac nos costaría
5,10 dólares.
Es decir, es mucho más caro que otros países
como Reino Unido, Canadá o Dinamarca.
Según la web EXPATISTAN.COM, Sao Paolo es
la ciudad más cara de toda América del Sur,
con unos precios muy parecidos a los de otras
ciudades como Houston, en Estados Unidos o
Berlín, en Alemania.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Cuánto ganan los brasileños
para poderse permitir este coste de vida?
¿Son más ricos que los colombianos o los
chilenos?
Lo cierto es que no.
Es salario medio en Brasil no llega a los
600 dólares mensuales.
Sin ir más lejos, los argentinos o los chilenos
tienen sueldos más generosos.
Así que la pregunta es ¿Por qué Brasil
es tan caro?
¿Cuáles son las razones que explican que
un país de renta media tenga unos precios
de país rico?
Hoy vamos a responder a esta pregunta.
Y, creedme, esto explica en buena medida muchos
de los problemas que han llevado a Brasil
a la crisis que está sufriendo estos días.
Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
UNA ECONOMÍA AISLADA DEL EXTERIOR
Muchos pensaríais que Brasil es un país
abierto al comercio internacional ¿Verdad?
A fin de cuentas, muchas empresas internacionales
como el Banco Santander o Telefónica tienen
presencia en este país desde hace años.
Sin embargo, Brasil tiene los aranceles más
altos de toda Latinoamérica ¿Y esto qué
significa?
Pues bien, imaginad que tenemos una empresa
que fabrica teléfonos móviles en Estados
Unidos y queremos vender en el mercado brasileño.
Pues bien, por el mero hecho de vender un
producto hecho en otro país, tenemos que
pagar un impuesto especial, que puede superar
el 35% del precio de mercado.
Y como os podéis imaginar, este tipo de políticas
tienen consecuencias muy claras para los ciudadanos.
“Nintendo se marcha del Mercado brasileño
debido a los altos aranceles”
Tal cual como lo oís.
Durante varios años, los brasileños que
querían comprarse una WII o una Nintendo
DS tenían que viajar a Uruguay para encontrarla.
Curiosamente, esto supuso una ventaja fenomenal
para sus competidores, sobretodo Microsoft
y su Xbox ¿Sabéis por qué?
Pues porque Microsoft tiene una planta en
Brasil donde fabrica la Xbox ONE.
Es decir, que no la tiene que importar.
¡Y ya sé lo que estáis pensando!
Que poner aranceles altos está muy bien porque
obliga a las empresas extranjeras a poner
fábricas en el país y dar trabajo a los
ciudadanos ¿Verdad?
¡Pues realmente no es así!
Pensadlo bien.
Cuando Microsoft monta una fábrica en Brasil,
necesita importar las máquinas con las que
ensamblan los componentes, cortan los plásticos
etc…
Y muchas de esas máquinas vienen de otros
países, lo que significa que pagan un impuesto
especial y, al final, son mucho más caras
que si la fábrica estuviera en otro país
con menos aranceles ¿Y quién paga este sobrecosto?
Efectivamente, el consumidor final.
Eso explica que incluso muchos productos fabricados
en Brasil como, por ejemplo, algunos modelos
de VOLKSWAGEN, sean extremadamente caros.
Para que os hagáis una idea, si compráis
un VOLKSWAGEN GOLF en Ciudad de México, os
costaría unos 15.000 USD mientras que en
Sao Paolo tendríais que apoquinar más de
25.000 USD.
Y todo esto, pese a que este modelo de coche,
concretamente, está fabricado en las afueras
del mismo Sao Paulo.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque esta no es
la única razón que explica este CUSTO BRASIL!
“CUSTO” LOGÍSTICO
Imaginad un agricultor que cultiva SOJA en
el estado de Pará, al norte del país.
Si quiere transportar un cargamento para venderlo
en Sao Paulo, debería enviarlo en un camión
y pasar por la autopista BR-163.
Pues bien, de los 1000 kilómetros que tiene
esta carretera, 100 no tienen ni siquiera
alquitrán.
Basta con que un día llueva para que los
camiones no puedan pasar o se queden hundidos
en el fango.
¡Pero este es sólo un ejemplo más!
Lo cierto es que Brasil tiene una de las peores
infraestructuras del mundo.
Incluso un país como LA INDIA tiene mejores
carreteras.
Para que os hagáis una idea, para un agricultor
estadounidense, cada vez que un agricultor
estadounidense vende 100 dólares de soja,
se tiene que gastar 9 en costes de transporte.
Ese mismo agricultor en Brasil tendría que
gastarse 25 dólares.
A falta de carreteras, los brasileños invierten
en camiones que se estropean a menudo y que
encarecen aún más los costes.
Lógicamente, todo esto también se traduce
en precios más altos para todos los bienes
que se venden en Brasil.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Por el Gobierno de Brasil
no invierte en infraestructuras?
A fin de cuentas, tienen empresas punteras
como…
el GRUPO ODEBRECHT.
Seguro que a todos los que veáis este vídeo
desde Latinoamérica os sonará el nombre.
Odebrecht era la empresa de construcciones
y de ingeniería más grande de toda la región.
Y digo “era” porque después de protagonizar
el mayor escándalo de corrupción de la historia
de todo el continente, es difícil saber lo
que va a pasar con esta empresa.
Y esto, explica, en parte, porque Brasil tiene
unas infraestructuras tan cochambrosas.
A fin de cuentas, buena parte del dinero se
va en sobornos y tráfico de influencias.
¡Pero no sólo eso!
¿Cuál fue la brillante idea del Gobierno
de Brasil para modernizar su país?
¡Efectivamente!
Juegos Olímpicos y Mundial de Fútbol.
Hoy en día, las grandes ciudades brasileñas
tienen unos preciosos estadios, con luces
y tecnología puntera.
Sin embargo, fuera de esas metrópolis, nos
encontramos con ferrocarriles abandonados,
autopistas sin asfaltar o incluso barrios
enteros que no tienen una simple línea de
autobús que les conecte con la ciudad.
Las infraestructuras lamentables de Brasil
cuestan a la economía nacional más de 48.000
Millones de Dólares al año.
Por supuesto, esto no sólo tiene consecuencias
en los precios que pagan los brasileños sino
también en los precios que pagamos en el
resto del mundo por los productos que se fabrican
en Brasil.
Pero de eso hablaremos en otro vídeo.
Porque ahora la pregunta que os estaréis
haciendo es…
¿Cómo alguien que gana menos de 600 dólares
al mes se puede gastar 25 en comerse una pizza
en un restaurante normal en San Paulo?
Ahora lo vamos a ver…
ENGANCHADOS AL CRÉDITO
Durante décadas, Brasil tenía una de las
inflaciones más altas del mundo.
En los años 80 y 90, llegaron a superar el
6000% de tasa de inflación interanual.
Para que os hagáis una idea.
Imaginad que en 1980 os tomáis una cerveza
en un bar de Río de Janeiro.
Esa cerveza os cuesta, vamos a decir, 100
cruceros.
El crucero era la divisa que usaban en aquella
época.
Pues bien, un año más tarde, en el mismo
bar, esa misma cerveza os costaría 600.000
cruceros.
Como os podéis imaginar, esta HIPERINFLACIÓN
creó unos hábitos de consumo muy distintos
a los que tenemos en el resto del mundo.
Para sobrevivir, las tiendas brasileñas se
acostumbraron a vender productos a plazos.
Y estas estrategias continúan siendo muy
útiles en un país con unos precios tan altos.
Por eso, todavía hoy podemos ver los precios
de las tiendas con un numerito al lado que
puede decir 10x, 12x o 20x.
Ese número y esa “x” significa que puedes
pagar ese producto en 10, 12 o 20 plazos.
Dicho de otra forma.
La pregunta que se hacen muchos brasileños
no es si este traje, o esta televisión, es
cara o barata sino si podré pagar los plazos
en los próximos dos años.
Y como os podéis imaginar, cuando pagas algo
a plazos, te sale mucho más caro.
Por ejemplo, aquí tenemos un smartphone en
un ecommerce brasileño.
Si os fijáis, pagándolo de una sola vez,
nos cuesta 632 reales, que serían como unos
202 dólares.
Sin embargo, pagándolo a plazos nos costaría
el equivalente a 217 dólares.
Un 7% de diferencia que se suma a los demás
sobrecostos de los que hemos hablado ya.
Todo esto significa que el brasileño medio
está continuamente pagando deudas.
Y, lógicamente, esto tiene sus consecuencias.
“Cerca del 60% de los brasileños está
en deudas por los pagos plazos”
¡Pero esperad un momento porque esto no es
lo peor de todo!
En los últimos años, ha aparecido un nuevo
elemento que ha elevado este CUSTO BRASIL
a unas cotas verdaderamente NACHOVIDALIANAS.
LAS TARJETAS DE CRÉDITO
A principios de los años 2000, Brasil se
convirtió en la niña bonita de todos los
bancos.
Grandes entidades como el Santander o Credit
Suisse dispararon sus inversiones en el país.
Hablamos de un mercado con más de 200 millones
de habitantes, que estaba en pleno crecimiento,
donde los precios son altos y la población
está acostumbrada a consumir cosas pagándolas
a plazos.
En otras palabras, Brasil era el lugar perfecto
para vender tarjetas de crédito.
“Desde 2005, el mercado de tarjetas de crédito
en Brasil ha crecido en más de un 20% cada
año”
En el año 2012, los brasileños ya tenían
una media de 2 tarjetas de crédito por persona.
¡Y las usaban como si no existiera mañana!
Brasil era el país que más dinero gastaba
en crédito, per cápita, de toda Latinoamérica.
Sin embargo, estas alegrías durarían bastante
poco.
“La morosidad en las tarjetas de crédito
de Brasil alcanza un 27% en abril de 2012”
En el año 2012, saltaron las alarmas en todos
los bancos del país.
En un país en crisis, donde el desempleo
crece y los sueldos bajan, es muy difícil
devolver las deudas ¿Y qué pasa cuando un
banco tiene miedo de los morosos?
¡Efectivamente!
Sube los tipos de interés.
“Los Brasileños tienen que pagar un interés
del 414% en sus tarjetas de crédito”
Imaginad que utilizamos la tarjeta para comprar
una televisión que cuesta 1000 USD.
Y la pagamos en 12 plazos mensuales.
Pues bien, al final del año, sumando los
intereses, la televisión nos habría costado
5000 USD.
No está mal ¿verdad?
Y ¡ojo!
Que no se nos olvide que el salario medio
en Brasil ni siquiera llega a los 600 dólares
al mes.
En otras palabras que por muchas medidas que
se pongan para luchar contra la pobreza, la
mayoría de los brasileños viven en condiciones
de subsistencia.
Y lo que es peor, apenas pueden ahorrar dinero,
con lo que si pierden el trabajo, no tienen
un colchón para poder sobrevivir.
Y eso explica noticias como esta.
Los sin-techo en Río de Janeiro aumentan
en un 150% en sólo tres años.
Mientras tanto, el presidente de Brasil, Michel
Temer, está acusado por cargos de corrupción
y tiene la popularidad por los suelos.
Y los anteriores presidentes están igual
o peor.
Lula da Silva ya está en la cárcel por tráfico
de influencias y Dilma Roussef tuvo que abandonar
su cargo en 2016.
Si queréis conocer algo más sobre ese escándalo
Odebrecht que ha sumido a Brasil en el caos
político, haced click en este vídeo.
Y ahora la pregunta es ¿Puede Brasil salir
de esta situación?
¿Quién puede reformar el país?
En fin…
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Como siempre, no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que suscribíos
al canal para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un abrazo y hasta pronto.